you
hi everyone it's Jerry I am tuned in
right now watching Magnus play Ollie
chess he just hopped into the bullet
shield arena about ten minutes ago I
just found out he was playing so I
figured I'd record a little bit of his
play he is officially in berserk mode so
these are one-minute games but he's
clicking on berserk in everyone so far I
believe so that cuts his time in half so
he's basically playing hyper bullet
versus his opponents who currently very
low rated compared to him everybody's
low rated compared to him he's at 29 18
I don't believe he's going to be gaining
any points for a little bit he's
currently 380 third in this tournament
and there is about an hour and 15 to go
so I don't know if he's gonna compete in
the rest of it just I guess sit back and
observe him go into berserk mode for a
little bit and maybe once he gets to
page one if he does hit page one he'll
be encountering some
AIIMS so that that'll definitely be
interesting to see if he play some im's
and berserks them see if he could win
those games so it's currently up a
couple pieces here and 21 seconds is
plenty it's in fact evening out on the
clock now so I'm gonna jump over to the
page standing so you can see the
tournament page standings the bullet
shield arena you can see he's in 380
third and we'll see where the rest of
the field is really quick after this
game it's already even on the clock and
f2 is collapsing and immediately mate so
you know well he's always back there are
1400 players in the tournament
1413 at the moment just got paired up
again again State 2046 once again going
berserk so 30 seconds versus a minute I
haven't seen this before I mean I've
seen other players berserk but this the
first time I'm seeing Magnus berserk so
should be interesting
playing against this structure has
enough file to work with and I guess the
Knights gonna be playing very soon
actually this is just collapsing due to
the pin on the G file
yeah and if the Queen moves there's f7
no good solution here probably a quick
resign these games seem to be finishing
much faster than a minute the main to
threat rook has to come over
defends maybe something like this as
well
once again maybe gonna put both rooks on
the Oh what's this trick and he's
getting the two pieces he's actually
ahead on the clock yeah definitely has
some wheels and I know again I don't
think he even went up a single point
from his close to eight wins now in the
tournament
okay he's quickly moving up the ranks
three hundred and twentieth he's now in
two hundred and seventy second place
yeah he's in he's in an all-out berserk
mode and this is an issue he's up upon
we can kingside structure and now just
cracking things open this diagonals now
in issue these ideas right around the
corner if possible a pivot here but not
right now because of the bishop yeah
that minimum there's a knight f to move
Knight F to even in here yeah he's he's
really trying to make this happen
g5 cuts off the bishop Queen h6 in to h2
is the idea and is giving up some
material now bone and saw that he got
the rook or the Queen deadly night on e3
there she goes another quick resigner
270 second place let's see where he
jumps up to next how many points does he
have he's not in another game just yet
270 second dr. drunk
got in another game and I want to step
away from this there's still an hour 10
so this would be pretty impressive I'm
forgetting how long the bullet shield
arenas are I'll take a peek at that
right after this game
way up development wise b7 is collapsing
the 95 is right around the corner he's
just tearing through these players as
you would expect Bishop takes and now
there's Anna he's in a pin he could take
the night with check who cares about the
rook he's mopping up both minor pieces
or major pieces I should say doesn't
want that Queen b3 and then just scoops
the bishop up on e2 Knight f4 into here
the queen is very short on squares he's
up a piece in another and he had me
right there Denny Queen to d7 13 seconds
we go on to win this one as well
230 fourth place
okay I'm gonna take a peek
yeah matin - mm-hmm
checkmate so where is yet doctor drunken
Stein is currently in yeah that's his
streak all-out berserk he's in another
game 200 in first place so he's gaining
fives he might be able to catch it
you might be able to get first
yeah yeah look at
quick that this game is gone that was a
fast one so he is now jumping up to
where 160th with one hour and eight
minutes to go okay and the bullet shield
is a four hour tournament that's what I
wanted to check right here bullet arena
four hours
okay is he gonna get paired up again or
has he had enough maybe he's not gonna
play anymore
195 spectators
let's see if he gets another game in
there yeah maybe he logged off no it's
just not in the game yet mmm maybe he's
done playing he's had enough no he has
not had enough
okay we got a 2,200 now
he's still in there maybe he paused for
a second or just a little delay it's
very difficult to organize some attack
even though this file is completely
opened when there's an unopposed dark
square Bishop also makes life difficult
when White is now down a piece and a
pawn
sixteen seconds oh boy these bishops are
killers 12 seconds to do it against a
2,200 yeah this is this is hitting very
fast he should be able to pre move this
one out yeah eight seconds and he's
getting a touchdown here two cleans in a
blink and mate right away with plenty of
plenty of seconds to spare 160 first I
think he's if I had to guess I don't
know if he's just gonna jump in and not
play the rest of this one out it's just
an hour to go and he's doing this
berserk thing I think he's in for the
rest of it so this is interesting
it's just checking some messages when I
fired up my computer today and then
realized he was he was flying so a
caro-kann what's this what's this thing
about some h6 was initially to provide a
square for the bishop but then a change
of plans huh h5 looking to rattle the
night position okay ready to take on
that square twice win upon and he has to
go on
castled giving up the bishop
both sides are castled this is an issue
and that is an issues why this this is a
familiar idea to me I I think I had this
position once in an over the board game
playing the karo con just this idea of a
double attack
I'm Genji - and then some some skewer on
that diagonal my opponent didn't fall
for it but just this idea playing within
this structure having that doubled F
pawns and the G file to work with anyhow
this one's over he was actually ahead on
the clock and he's now in 129th place
this is the top page so you see a couple
AIIMS FM's
are on that first page so and he
actually gained his first point not sure
about that last game so this is a double
berserk game Jabari is very excited
about some little night dance and then
in the end he's a danced to match he's
gonzo and there goes the Queen yeah this
one's over this is uh this will be over
in less than a minute has a nice shot
Bishop takes d7 and now they're just
sweeping in a mate in two threat I don't
see how you defend that pawn move Bishop
move it doesn't matter
these next two moves are happening
just gonna let his time run shabari
come on man
I guess it's a clock ticker yeah even
even carlson gets known a fried it
happens okay is he going to be in the
top 100 now with one hour and three
minutes to go yes 90 third place less
than 30 yeah all out berserk he's played
this in the elite bold arena this
caro-kann capturing on f6 with the e
pawn it's a mouse slip man - Bishop
takes Bishop and now the dark squares
are collapsing meat in through mating -
quick kill against a 2184 who did not
preserve back in that one does he get a
point for that one at least 93rd where
does he jump up to next with this five
that's what he's getting fives for every
win
is he in a game yet yes he's in a game
he'll play the rest of this one hour to
go and he's in 79th he's in it to win
for sure very interesting a very nice
surprise
all right a nice little fork that
happened there and breaking up the
pollen duo you know it's a minor piece
game this is a liability in this
position type isolated pond it's way too
simplified for there to be some kind of
an attack against the black king okay
it's not isolated anymore but there
should be some light square issues
fourteen white keeping pressure on III
this is a nineteen eighteen player
Rickey rich you know that here's another
thing this is a pretty cool thing for I
mean this is pretty neat actually I'm
just thinking thinking now this isn't a
titled arena this is
you know you have an opportunity here to
play against a world champion so I'm
sure I'm sure every opponent here as
he's working his way up to this first
page where he will be getting paired
with titled players this is a just a
great experience and get to say you
played the world champ pretty neat I
have yet to play against him where's the
mate
there it is alright Lord
Bendtner 2404 getting berserk let's see
do we call this an all-out berserk for
Magnus or hyper bullet Magnus
we're almost at the one our point is
this guy gotta move he left the game
maybe a connection issue in a quick a
quick win yeah black didn't move
those are some easy points or is it yet
now fifty second place he's paired up
again against Peter pun three now he
does have he only got four points for
that game
Hebrews irked but because his opponent
didn't move he only gets four there's a
that's one of the one of the rules there
it's going to be winning material that
deep on is dangerous
hmmm interesting to see the pawn
captures maybe there was going to be a
sacrifice on e4 and another quick
resigner Wow interesting he just blocked
gave a check and then said you know what
I've had enough
okay forty fifth place
Maur marklar marklar marklar squared we
have 1923
maybe he's gonna crack 3000 as well as
winning this tournament we'll see 59
minutes to go dark square weaknesses
what to do looking for a 5 picking up
this pawn rook here there's a fork there
are no good checks for black well forget
it just just no checks in the position
difficult to defend this pawn something
simple like doubling up
there's Knight b7 if he wants it could
also view it as you know the knight is
pretty valuable on c5 but he goes in for
it is up the exchange that might be
right around the corner
sticking upon on f6 and then getting in
on the dark squares is is possible there
goes the night he's up a full rook and
this is easily converted King prevents
the pawn or the bishop can do that and
he'll be cleaning house in this one soon
enough no fancy stalemates and just
resigned another 5 which is going to put
him soon I won't have to search for him
he is in 36th with how many games he's
played 19 games missed about the first 5
of this one godlike moves is the next
opponent a Sicilian on board quick
strike at f7f - it's weird to defend
like that
Bishop is in the way and he's insisting
on crashing through here there isn't
this there isn't this Knight to e4 move
and now there goes the bishop and the
structure and b2 is ready to fall Queen
B for Queen a5 the knight has to return
oh can he come back against God like
well he didn't take the Queen Magnus was
pre moving there thinking that he was
just going to take the Queen after this
I guess you have to
kind of guess a little bit when you're
in hyper bullet mode dodged a bullet
there that would have been interesting
to see if he could have come back being
down a queen and a lot of time and he's
fighting back on the clock it's evening
out and this is excellent for Team Black
Knight is flushed away e5 is falling
these guys will be set into motion this
guy can collapse at any moment now that
the knight is in the way of the Queen
and he's up on the clock crashing
through now and f2 taking with the rook
fancy okay these guys are pushing
through tsunami of pawns just keep on
marching who needs the king or the rook
at this point time out for team white
another W which is gonna put him up to
what place 29th place okay here we go
he's going to be encountering these
bigger dogs with 56 minutes to go in the
tournament this bullet shield arena
24:45 player so he's going to gain a
point maybe just for this win if he gets
it bruiser King a 24 45 solid structure
ties in well with this Bishop
seems like a pretty slow position and
which is probably good news for the for
this player you really have to change up
your approach here when you go into
berserk mode and kind of go for your
opponent's throat fast sharp positions
it's quite the maneuvering game but at
any moment this could turn into a well
how to say
a position where you could pre move out
so you can't be stuff to be very
attentive to the the position yeah the
night is
some trouble here 11 seconds he might
get his first loss here might have to
repeat go after F to target h3 this
square is covered I don't know if he has
anything after h4 got a check in there
how you defending h3 now there's Queen
f3 or h2o that's a problem
f2 Knight g3 as well is there a mate
it's not quite a may 25 seconds now
looking too good here he's gonna have to
use some pre-move magic clean here the
Queen's are off
can you pull this one out and now the
Knights gun and this is a loss for
Carlsen his only hope is the clock what
kind of magic and he stir up here it's
not looking too good
2.4 seconds maybe maybe this guy's a
little bit nervous no he should be able
to do it yeah black resigned it's tough
and who with that he goes down 37 points
that's not gonna be easy
berserk King 24 hundreds and some 2500
is playing as well no he's in 30th he's
not on streak his first loss was just
that last one so let's see if he could
get back on the horse yeah so I was
saying earlier on that was a little bit
too much maneuvering going on in that
one plenty of the games earlier were
quick kills and he got sharp f5 is
falling
that's close by yeah doesn't want the
night to get it back in there these
bishops are killers
basically controlling all these light
and dark squares and this pawn is
pushing through and on the night is
there to defend killer bishops look at
how quick oh that is so nice that was a
really nice move Knight there Knight
takes promotion with mate okay
so we're we out here how many points
does he have 98 points he's in 28th the
52 minutes to go he's back in there he's
not going to be hitting 2300 I don't
think but can he win the tournament
he's not gonna hit 3000 I'm not sure
what I just said there it's not gonna
hit 3000 but can you win the tournament
let's see hmm and he's gonna be winning
upon here and well yeah at least upon
okay
this night is rescued isn't it no not
here you could take because the queen is
unprotected there's no recapture so he's
falling pawn wise where do we stand he's
gonna be up a couple pawns king or you
don't even have to take he doesn't want
the night he wants the bishop okay and
flush the night away I flushed the Queen
away and take the knight doesn't even
want the knight he's basically saying
you know what the knight is under
control I just want to get on with
pushing this guy so now he's up at these
14 seconds to go plenty is gonna be
promoting yeah there's a free Queen yeah
and the rook is gonna fall soon new
Queen right around the corner yeah mate
in two or one no I mean one I was
thinking this kind of thing okay another
W and I think with that he's now back on
streak so this next win would be a five
he has 101 points the tournament leader
has 216 hmm is it possible is it
possible we're gonna find out okay Maran
29 FM opponent berserk berserk he's made
that decision long ago in the hall out
berserk what was this a Tron popskyy a
court grip in the center you don't see
this structure so quick so he's looking
for something on the G file soon no not
so fast because of this pressure here
and now giving up upon some Benko like
idea for some play on the Queen side
central pawn majority these guys are
ready to roll in here they go so is the
idea with this little b5 move acquire a
strong pawn center both bishops fiend
keto to the light square weaknesses
around the White King the Knights ready
to pivot here and look at how quick he
knows he's there to defend against g6
the pawns continue to march feel that
it's possible for Queen gaeaf oh nice
okay well it's not losing material with
that but he's getting rid of the Queen
Knights having a difficult time finding
a good square so is the bishop the King
could play a role these pawns continue
to march he's gonna be winning some
material and he's gonna go on to win
this one seven seconds is plenty he'll
be able to pre move this one out six
seconds yeah simple enough
take the pond and push this guy to
Victory Lane three seconds may preserve
to 2400 on the nose
FM goes down okay it's June 23rd place
48 minutes to go let's see
fast you know this is this is very
interesting first time I'm seeing hyper
bullet the hyper bullet Carlson I mean
yeah didn't see any of that in the
titled arena so he's up upon pick that
guy off with check he's now up a piece
on his playing maybe a little bit too
fast here hmm okay well the F file shut
down this is a possibility at some point
I thought last novus was there it's it's
there once more just doesn't want to
allow Queen takes h4 or anything just
controlling the only open file and this
queen is getting squeezed and this King
is in a giant box and just gonna go for
o gonna go for the mate on the H file
the old switcheroo
I was just thinkin you push through here
nope there's something faster the bishop
controls this
sideways mate I guess okay he's in 19th
berserk again 2192 is an opponent is the
opponent isolated pond h2 is threatened
he's gonna focus on d4 now first just
take out the dark square Bishop and now
Queen should take up a really nice post
on d4 an enormous Knight no first black
takes that out so rook and pawn endgame
the endgame wizard can he do it the
rooks are very active these pawns are
all very weak one rook off is cool
phones negate these three so carlson is
playing up upon well yeah here he's
already up upon I was just thinking well
my thing he was off with that one he's
just up a clean pond here
Oh King and pawn endgame is winning so
that's why you take with the king there
seven seconds to pull this one off let's
see he could take him at any moment
first improves the King position six
seconds take one of them this is the
more important one now there's two
connected passers and he's pushing
through five seconds and here we go the
whole step ladder mate 19th place uh-oh
that's not good news the site went down
now it's back up that was two men in an
issue on my end
Jonah be 94
next opponent
berserk 2500 is getting berserk okay
what two notes well getting the exchange
and yeah he's up the exchange targeting
a five now three times its hip has been
close to pre moving this one out
the night is offset by the bishop giving
some material back to wipe out the Queen
side pawns two to zero on the Queen side
more exchanges wine up target the night
and this is going to be a win no good
solution here oh he's being sneaky
there really wasn't a way out of that
pin securing the bishop with h6 but this
is still going to be a win just take the
night with check two queens three point
six seconds take the Queen you should be
able to preme in this room pre move this
one out one second watch off her
stalemate no stalemates one second on
the nose he went up plus three with that
one in a very fast pairing with 44
minutes to go on this bullet shield
arena members arcing again against L
drill alright a double fianchetto all
righty
let's see how to play within the
structure it's just amazing to see how
good the chest still is at this fast
pace okay and this diagonal is not the
greatest anymore so quick reposition
Knights following on a very good square
the H pon might look to roll very soon
the night is ready to move now that the
rook is defended Carlson controls the
only open file the bishop is hit queen
is hit it's gonna be winning upon I
don't know how valuable it is the night
could be defended I don't know how you
take advantage of the night position
actually he's up the exchange and I have
known it I totally missed where that
even happened how he how he managed to
be up the exchange it's too too
difficult to keep up with this speed he
is even on the clock
target f7 no it's targeting the knight
he's now up a full rook less than 10 to
go and this is an easy one to pre move
they could pick up this guy at any point
that could be this I would rather have
my bishop there that way there's no
sneaky pawn move five seconds to go
flying watch out for steal mates there
will be no stalemates rook here next and
that's the ballgame two point one to
spare he's in 18th place coming up the
ranks
126 once he gets to this first page he's
likely to hit one of these two guys
Lord venture 99 is the punt second time
playing space on the Kings side with f5
looking to break things open on this
side of the board he's controlling the
whole board
b3 was probably a primo of a fors
maybe better to prevent a b5 clean is
slipping in h6 is under fire and cannot
be defended smashing through King move
there might be a night block
with Czech where's the mate
or something like this I've six and then
here it's closed Queen here It's Made on
the spot searching for mate oh that's
very nice Queen takes pawn takes and
then there's an issue with the pin do we
need the help of the rook you could
always pick up pick up the bishop there
the goes of the bishop
it's insisting on this pin still
insisting on this pin rook here you
could take could simplify everything
needs up a pawn or excuse me up a piece
and we'll go on to win this one he's got
everything to past pawns
watch out for steel mates the only thing
and there will be no stalemate it's not
happening 6.8 seconds to spare another
quick pairing against Jonah be 90 for
2495 opponent he's at 29:57 I think he
would have broken 3000 if he didn't have
that one loss
yeah
no already it's giving up a pond he does
have some play though now with castles
there's an open F file to work with
targeting c4 this is a rock this is a
this is a good position for white how
can he fight back what kind of trouble
is he going to stir up okay he's gonna
put the knight on e6 it's important it's
a passer okay he has some okay now these
two pawns control these three so the
place should turn over here unless
there's some fancy tactic but I think
all these points are covered yeah
and this rook is this frickin get very
active okay he's just trying to lock
down everything he's dropping v6 but now
the knight is very active looking for a
fork on D - that's defended the rook is
active though maybe there's a mate right
around the corner the rook and Knight he
has a stable square he's down to less
than nine seconds though not looking too
good for Carlsen does it check another
check what kind of fancy thing can he
pull off I got a little repetition there
will be no repetition white wants to win
this one and there's a check notes I'm
just not happening he resigned goes down
39 he's in 13th place
13th place he has 131
okay here we go Lars Oh in international
master getting berserk to 2602 the
current leader of this bullet shield
arena let's see
well Carlson throws at him
the caro-kann and their right Bishop is
outside of the pawn chain is a Karel con
player that's what you want to do
it's the idea get that piece active
alright well this is a completely
wrecked kingside structure and this rook
Queen and Bishop are going to do
something dangerous against the King
know something something bad is
happening B to e through you're hit 21
seconds to go
queenside castle watch out for D for
bringing that fourth and final piece
into the attack and this King is without
a home there goes e3 here comes d4 look
out for d3 no don't forget about the
crazy C fun
here comes d3 pawn takes pawn and that's
killer
rook takes pawn what are you doing about
this this is collapsing fast and the
time difference isn't even that much
a check a capture and a mate on b2 you
see how easy see how easy it is a to
beat and I am and the site goes down oh
man no its back up it must be something
with my computer I don't know man
it's really not that easy he just kind
of makes it look easy as all that says
that's a tough opponent
allora saw the Norwegian ninja next
opponent 20300 let's see I think with
this with this win here if he if he
pulls off a win he's up the exchange
I think he'll break into that first page
he's very close to doing that let's see
how he converts this the Knights are
covering a lot of ground there weren't
very many squares for the rook but he's
found a way out trading some you know
how to convert this Knight f4 is hit
with e5 alright and there you go
Knight spins and that's that's going to
be that
yeah the ponds gonna push through no
stalemates and that's mate
the Norwegian ninja goes down in a very
fast paring Sicilian dragon there are
510 spectators here I believe you could
see that in there I have that captured
for this video 540 it just keeps growing
he's in 11th place flying okay
knight on the on the rim huh he's okay
with whatever kind of structure doubled
pawns here upon that's kind of split
there it's targeted Queens there to
defend where to deploy the bishop that
seems most active King side Castle I see
any reason not to King side Castle King
safety in the corner rook activity on
the F file Knight f4 right around the
corner bishop on e3 is what he wants
there's a check he's super glued in
there g2 is an issue King in the corner
rook on g8 what to do about the G to
point he wants a queen exchange
interesting this is White's past piece
so and the structural change benefits
white now these guys are past two to one
majority you can't take the night
because of maid aroni 16 seconds he's
ahead on the clock a Sicilian drag in
2018 is an 1815 opponent 89th in the
tournament you know I'm sure
these uh players will be saying I got to
play the champ that's pretty cool well
he's pushing through time is an issue in
fact white it's gonna lose on time with
this one
yeah time out so where are we at here he
is officially intense with 142 245 is in
first and it's gonna be a tough one to
track down probably impossible right
around this point but let's let's see
what kind of good games we can get in
here the regos and all-out berserk maybe
with another half-hour of playing he
could have reeled in the first first
place or the the bullet shield let's say
tens place pressure against 'if I've
learned a seven majority on the kingside
it's it's in motion now before these
pieces are very clumsy now so continuing
to push through d6 is collapsing oh wow
what's that about just wants to push on
through can't take twice here gonna
promote yeah is just insisting will not
be denied that promotion the Queen is
now gone for team black easy win with 12
seconds is he on streak
believe he's on streak so I'll be
getting another five for this one 33
minutes to go in the tournament let's
see
that is me
he is in ninth with 147 let's refresh
and there we go
okay Merrin Buren 29 again they've been
no neon board this is a nice move to get
in exchange the bishop for Knight
usually a difficult piece to get working
in the Benoni but he's long gone
traded for the knight expanding in the
queenside b2 is an issue Bishop and rook
make life a little bit difficult
defending this point converging on the
Queen side two to one on the Queen side
and they just continued to push on
through the night is on c5 looking for
some nice jumping points d3 b3 b3 cuts
off the defense of d6 rook d4 cuts off
the defense of d6 he still lives there
both past track down this guy's the I
would think is number one priority
Bishop takes pawn can you get away with
that he just wants to hunt down this guy
first things first
not a lot of time nine seconds looking
for a check now you used to track this
down even if the Queen's are exchanged
oh hang on Queen block and there's
Bishop takes h2 Queen check on f4 Oh in
the Queen Esther block and its mate next
F tude near n29 got F tude scholars mate
style Wow
yeah I was thinking the Queen blocks
here but that would have allowed Bishop
takes h2 deflection then Queen takes
Queen and the Queen would have been
around soon enough to stop that D pawn
all right seventh place 31 minutes to go
yeah this is fun very fun
okay and d5 that's a big square for a
knight and what's he gonna do nothing
there wasn't a good square is up a piece
all right
how to convert put pressure on the H
file yeah he has the F file to work with
Bishop takes d6 at some point Knight f6
with Queen here King move you have to
sack the Queen right now otherwise
maintenance may next Queen here
pick your favorite square actually back
to tournament what am i doing I'm saying
back to tremor and I'm not even playing
that's when you think played too much
okay oh this is a double berserk game
opera is the opponent current score here
is seven oh how to fight back it's down
upon a double berserk okay
Queens are gonna be off Knight there is
a nice shot oh he's being very sneaky
with f6 he didn't move either rook Wow
Carlson has some tricks up his sleeve
man oh and another trick Bishop takes h7
woo Opera was in the driver's seat if he
just was a little bit more disciplined
right there he was gonna Bank that
material and go on to win I feel very
confident about that but it just wasn't
meant to be he's he was sneaky Carlson
is a sneaky player we're also seeing
here a little pawn jab f6 instead of
moving either rook okay f5 is nice
looking for something on the kingside
here Queen f6 Noel now there's some new
possibilities over here he's going to
play on the Queen side or the king side
this is where the action is watch out
for the mates
Knight h4 into g6 King up now just just
Castle castle and then double now you're
just stepping up doing this and then
this might become an issue now the rook
is playing where is there some fancy
tactic the bishop may be rerouting over
here this may be an idea now he's
dropping some material but is this a
threat even know there isn't some threat
here this night what did tal say about
that guy night on f8 no mate doesn't
seem to be a mate I don't see it he's
covering this there isn't a mate he's
going to try to smash through here China
no it's I don't see this one happening
here here maybe if you get the knight on
f5 it's something different
he's gonna try something hang on 15
seconds mates right here how do you stop
mate here
you don't oh this is just next oh okay
there's a fancy little check there just
got made
Mishka the great went down okay
hammer time
gen Ludwig hammers getting berserk he
doesn't want to preserve back he wants
to he wants to win this one all right
you know this is a super invasive pawn
on h3 this would be very impressive
breeze arcing a 2721 battled the
Norwegians and they're right F file play
here we go light squares
and negate that rook and this is gonna
be a positional battle 20 seconds
what's wrong with Knight takes pawn
there now he's he wants to hang on to
that guy and pour oh he just dropped his
rook he forgot that the rook was hanging
Carlson's gonna win 16 seconds is plenty
he's up a rook oh man
has a very bad blunder
you know you just overlook that the rook
was hanging there happens
nine seconds how to convert this his
upper rook not easy well he's got a
passer rook takes phone and he's pushing
through
I got a check in that promotion he wants
to promote another pond so fast
get to that pre-move point premium point
point four seconds he never he never
ended up taking that piece he's down on
time
he didn't convert that one Wow oh man
up a rook but hammer came back on the
clock
hmm there had to be a better way you
have to get rid of that final piece by
your opponent at that stage and then you
could pre move out it just never
happened that rook hammers rook stuck
around okay he's in sixth twenty five
minutes to go and take a peek at the
standings after this game l drill again
second time a nice square to work with
on d5 giving up I'm not giving up on
blundering up on and it was difficult to
defend so what to say about this one
it's looking pretty draw actually even
though white is up upon ten seconds
mm-hmm
this one's gonna be tough I don't see
how you ever get to a point as black
where you could pre me that pre move
this one out
rook here King there would be
embarrassing Oh his Gold's close to
happening but you have to come back over
here the king could try to get active
like this and he's making a break for Oh
actually in a pickle team white and can
you Preem with this or now not quite
1.7 seconds getting a queen oh he's is
he gonna win is he gonna win is he gonna
win Oh point one point zero one no not
quite lost on time he's in sixth let's
take a peek 168 well how how close can
you get to first he's not gonna get he's
not gonna get first maybe get stopped
three you're in 29 third time playing
okay this bishop should be basically
shut out of the game no what's his
future there's no caffeine there's no
good future oh hang on I was missing
that there's a bishop bishop move there
ah King comes over the rook it's flush
back is it a one King and pawning game
it is he is up a pawn after all so how
to how to break this an open in 83 b4
acquire a past C pawn C pawn is now
passed how to get him rolling defend
base points first and now scored the
pawn and he should be able to do this
there isn't enough checking distance
between the rook and the pawn if the
pawn was here in the rook was here it
would be a different story not the case
though he should be able to go all the
way down and that's a free rook and the
ball game black resigned 171 needs
another game to get into that streak
mode Elda 64
26:40 I am and yeah it's a double
berserk game holiday hyperbolic a Minnie
Mouse slip right out of the gates King
f8
Queen h6 shouldn't be too much of a
bother could be dislodged multiple ways
Queens off no staying around the night
is negated with c6 f5 break III is
collapsing this night is enormous
where's the main I feel like there
should be a mate close by some some
fancy really gain some material there it
is there goes the Queen wits check and a
quick resignation 26:40 goes down in
this double berserk game hyperbolic aim
fly in sky
getting reserved of resort back flying
sky we're going to see first time
playing hi
sky is almost certainly a titled player
yeah that would be my bet fm I am area
yep okay let's see not berserk him back
in this one
wanting to win this one let's see no
time to take B to the rook was hip
skewer Tom skier in town skewer town or
skewer time all right
c6 is a nice square hop right in Queen
takes Queen you could take on e7 first
that is RIT's Czech Queen to sit twice
God do something there we go
keep the Queen's on and how to pre move
out hang on there's a bishop c3 move if
you take that pawn he's gonna pile up
here this is not easy to break down this
rooks it's the bishops it's the
stability these guys need to change the
structure somehow because the base
points are all covered in sacking the
rook back for one of these - it's a dead
drawn position this rook is also very
good here again these guys need to
rattle the position somehow and here we
go but how do you break this down you
really need to exchange rooks there goes
the pawn though he's looking for mate
though and he's gonna get it he's going
to get the mate he switched it he used
this pawn as a form of uh wow this pawn
factors into this mating that idea
controlling these three squares and the
backdoor looked to what Square was that
rook to g8 idea very nice there was
nothing happening on that seventh rank
so had to try something on the eighth
rank very nice pawn on g5 and then
functioning on that eighth rank
meanwhile in this game he's up a queen
he's up a boatload of material Queen
slipping in and just giving some
material back to break things open
everything is falling Bishop queenside
castle sack the rook
hit him with a fork you follow Queen
here Queen there where's the mate here
it is back two tournaments and I'm not
even playing oh man where we ant he's in
fifth nineteen minutes to go an all-out
berserk yes it is 100% berserk another
opponent yes
Jonah be 94 split games
Karlsson versus a Carol con
no night exchange the night exchange
over here much different now the rook
gets to play controlling d4 with a three
blacks going for a light square bishop
exchange has that this is a very strong
night some tactics against this point
that's why the rook is needed to defend
the bishop it's just taking out that 90
is very strong yeah in game area queen
is now defended with the King creeping
closer f5 maybe close by yeah probably
gonna have to have the Queen's off in
this one in order to try to make some
progress but black keeps the Queen's on
makes difficult for Carlsen to go into
some pre move mode e six is targeted and
how do you uh how do you guard ecig
there's gonna be some checks thrown in
another check and then Queen here seems
nice here we go
Queen here is an idea it's not looking
good for team white yeah with five
seconds to go and still a lot of
different moves that can keep white in
check
literally and just you know keeps keeps
white on as he can't pretty move this
one out there was an opportunity there
for Queen takes Knight and he's just
down a time and certainly position here
okay
did not work out there for Carlson lar
so again the number one guy in this
tournament but that is not a lock hopper
is right on his heels fourteen points
back
okay well dark squares are a big issue
this is one it's already game over have
sevens crushing 16 mover honey like that
Wow okay
how did that one go kind of like that
this Bishop never played dark squares or
critical as soon as the dark square
bishop so often just a few moves later
back-breaking move f7 okay he's in fifth
he's on streak no he's not on streak
it's just his first win alrighty well
Knight takes pawn quick resigning
Queen is gone Knight takes Bishop Queen
takes Knight huh this is fine it's upper
rook you can easily convert this one and
you could pre move this one out
basically when fighting against a bishop
bishop could only control the light
squares in this case and that game
against hammer much different rook
there's me Bishop controls g1 having a
rook is much different work and control
everything Muir and 29 are pretty fast
pairing there 24:07 fourth game between
these two now a central majority looking
for each dream has it some weaknesses
around the King for sure Knight f2
something here as well you know pressure
against g3 the Knights are converging g5
has the support g3 is collapsing dark
squares critical Knight f4 something on
h3 I think that was one of the ideas
with this pawn pushed paved the way for
Queen Age 3 9 n f5 is strong but lacks
the support of a pond or a piece so he
quickly is gonzo 12 seconds to commit
this pressure on e 2 now the knight
needs to find a new home there's a check
here and a check there I got to go to a
different square check here Queen here
the King has to go forward where's
where's the mate going back there's a
check and then Queen Queen f2 Knight g3
main 2
and if he went forward I just got made
it and if he went forward there was
probably something good here okay forget
about that
we got another Battle of the Norwegians
berserk hammer let's see if you can get
them back can't go too far with the
Queen it's pressure the corner
was there an opportunity for a check
here now the night could have blocked
saved himself is the rook I'm gonna go
oh this is this should be a win queen h5
Bishop to d5 converging on these squares
this is a big problem
Queen h5 how are you defending this a
push like there there's a check and then
a checkmate hmm yeah just eliminating
the defender of h7 pawn takes Knights
made on the spot we've seen this ID
before with the bishop here and getting
this little Rick coming back to mate on
the H file this is game over and look at
the clock no time edge even hammer just
got preserved you could resign we also
have this idea which is nice also this
one so many different mates pick your
favorite right and here we go mate next
to one of these two let's see what the
pawn wants to do pawn up me anywhere
else Knight is not around to help time
is up
12 minutes to go alright he has now 200
points yeah another half-hour
and okay chess bras is in there a double
berserk game very cool hyper bullet so
chess prizes in 17 so he must have been
playing in this tournament for quite a
bit 800 in collet 909 hundred and eleven
spectators okay
upon carlson the night is under control
back rank issues bishop doesn't like
being on h2 these three can offset these
four even on the clock and this guy is
gonna fall and he's gonna get it made it
carlson went down in that one here
there's a check and then the rook goes
here ballgame the only way to stop mate
would be to block with the pawn or block
with the Queen on e8
quick win for chess bras and that one in
a double berserk game that is very nice
okay what to do Muir in ought to say
really
you're an 29 next opponent fifth time
playing this night is a very important
defender otherwise a two can collapse
is looking for the c5 square it's good
on its own and that much more if I can
hit with tempo be striking it the Queen
the rook is gone that wasn't the plan I
guess one of the ideas was to keep this
night in in a weird state fiend cut out
night not a good post usually here we go
Knight on c5 super dangerous
b4 King here and then b4 probably have
to keep the Queen's on something like
this yeah
supporting the knight don't really need
to certain you're gonna support the
knight got a main threat here you could
push the Queen is defended very tricky
these Knights are covering a lot of
ground and he's actually ahead on the
clock - fancy Knights it's gonna lose
some material now night here blocks the
defense he's being he's being sneaky not
the first time we've seen the sneakiness
that game against opera with f6 was our
first experience with sneaky Carlsen
this isn't gonna go well yeah black at
Preem of this for now yeah let's see the
speed very difficult to pre move yeah
he's
on time okay let's see we're where we
are at the meat on bone next opponent
this is a double berserk game with under
ten minutes to go in this tournament
all right he doesn't want this capture
on on c6 huh
okay this is excellent for Team black
Bishop hair weakened structure for white
how to get this bishop playing is the
only thing and it's easily solved there
it's now active and gone off is a collar
Bishop position this is a good structure
combat this guy and slight improvement
huh rook up base points are covered this
guy's going to roll at some stage break
down this structure and then transfer
over on the H file now these guys could
become a thorn h3 g3 in this case the h4
square is available first defending g6
queen is now gone
Queen deform seven seconds there goes
the rook there goes the Queen side pawns
and just wants some simplification now
these guys are going to roll can white
hold on here
yeah he's gonna run with this one how do
you stop that guy actually yeah this hit
switz tempo he meant this move okay this
is still winning 3.6 seconds and that's
a w in this double berserk game the
regos next opponent um I often make sure
to look at what the performance rating
is see what you know see what his
performance is his performance rating is
in this all-out berserk nearly nearly an
hour and a half of play an all-out
Berserker okay not a double berserk here
going in after the Dark Star bishops
number one defender a most valuable
player basically in this position type
in this exact position because of the
print and the pawn on f6 but in general
a very good defender a very good
attacker there goes the exchange and
butts we have a lot of pieces right
around the King and there goes the
exchange he's just up a piece now Oh
dominoes
that's how the pieces are falling
twenty-eight seconds to nine
you could pre move this one out this is
a W and that's a mate's seven minutes 11
seconds to go he is in fifth he may end
up getting third he has a chance to hit
the podium alrighty let's see here
there won't be any attack against the
black king in this structure no no crazy
epon to challenge the night this is a
strong defender there's an issue here
you know and now on the King side as
well because of that pressure on D for
taking out the night it's up some
material getting out of the pin and out
that diagonal out of the pin with a
punch against the bishop pressure here
ready to take the knight and maybe do
something on the second ranked Queen
wants to get over here possibly 18
seconds to go there goes the bishop
office of color Bishop ending
III can fall no the Queen could also
fall that's better
go for the Queen there's a check once a
III that's defended he could have
captured it takes and then he taken the
corner easy for me to say I'm not
playing and I'm not the one who has only
ten eleven seconds but that's a mate and
we got opera again into this double
berserk game watch out opera you got a
sneaky opponent they playing the same
line now not quite in the other game
they played the Bishop was on f4 I think
essential expansion on board Knight e3
that's prevented squares given up on d5
Queens are gone okay a check and these
guys continue to push the knight is
offset where's the knight go nowhere d6
is there to defend and night remains
watch out for the rook up and over the
knight is controlling these two squares
some point this can happen that's what
he's trying and he got it 14 seconds
each and maid on the board g5 was
necessary
our best
I guess there was a bishop or Knight on
g4 but g5 covering h4 was important
the regos again third time with less
than five minutes to go in the
tournament Carlson is now in fourth
close to podium land okay
the knight is the one of the weakest
pieces in this position it's an issue on
this diagonal there was a threat in that
square that pawn controlled the knight
but okay now they're exchanged and these
guys are rolling there is a four to
three majority the knight is super glued
in there picks up the exchanged f4 or e3
looking for f4
Queens are off Carlson's up the exchange
14 seconds to go he has a passer watch
out for the back rank back rank I do
know he wants a dark square he's winning
here now just get rid of that rook can
you pull that one off you have pin and
this pawn should run fast you could
actually take first and then go back
over this will be a win five seconds
should be able to pre move it out yeah
four seconds is plenty Queens are gonna
sweep over hitting with check in every
case straight to mate three minutes and
change to go let's see he is now in
third and that's probably where he's
gonna stay no he's not getting second
who's getting first I don't know are you
gonna get another game yes Larry F David
first time playing against Larry F David
think I've played against Larry f David
a handful of times yes okay so what do
we have here
okay pressure on this guy there's not a
knight around controlling h5 so this
launching of that H bond it's tempting
for sure and now keeping black guessing
it's gonna be capture or push who knows
no castling from team black there goes
the dark square bishop look up and over
its prevented pressure on the center
pressure here the Queen can't go too far
has a responsibility and now this King
is very clumsy taking upon Queen is
there hitting the rook the other wrecker
wants to come up and over and how do you
save the Queen here and then here and
I'm just going for a queen exchange
eight seconds I don't know it's not
looking too good
got to get written there's just too much
work to be done you know oh hang on
there's always a there's always a mating
net oh that one's painful that one is
painful Larry up David had his chance to
do some time burning tactics but yeah
check me ends the game let's now forget
about that oh man that one totally
caught me off guard okay you want to
jump in Knight but you might get trapped
where's your new home here you got to do
something like this
you got to prepare to run no he could be
captured no but there's a Pinner Oney
yeah he's a cook tonight
the regos is
go down 20 seconds how dangerous are
these guys is he's still far off things
are opening up over here f3 he can't go
too far he has a responsibility now he's
gonna be anchored in there and actually
hang on a rook move and there'd be Queen
here possibly
he's just sneaking in you look up and
over that's made on the spot how do you
like that 38 seconds to go that might
have been the last one it's gonna be one
more game in actually 267 each Wow
okay who knows who's gonna win this one
actually it's not going to be Carlsen
but there's a tie there 267 each in a
four-hour tournament very close I'll
have a look at it only only 12 seconds
to go crashing through on c6 up the
exchange now three seconds to go on the
tournament clock this is a this is a
double you sneaking in here here
probably smash this open and then
pac-man mode on the on the kingside the
Norwegian wind Norwegian ninja tongue
tied mayn't next that's the ballgame
probably have resigned time no that's a
mate that's it no more games in who won
Oh probably some type of a buzzer beater
huh in the end lar so took first opera
took second Carlson took third
interesting for sure very unexpected to
see that he was jumping into this one so
looking at the games played I'm not sure
if he played the whole thing I imagine
he did so somewhere where is he had 117
games played Opera had 95 so probably a
bit of a late join
and Carlson had 58 games 88% win rate
100% berserk rate that's cool
I was definitely interested to see how
his how he would do in hyperbole mode
and well we got to see that most of it
all but fought about five of these 58
games so this was the the top page 1775
and all first lar so opera magnus
carlsen doctor drunken stein flying sky
Mishka the great Larry F David that was
a painful loss that happens tank box 1
John Ludwig hammer chest bras Muir and
29 top 10 how many games did I think he
was going on in a lover's arc as well
close to it
98% berserk rape but Jelena had 45 games
inside it probably happened that when
Carlson hopped in we had many others
hopping in that's my guess but anyhow
just this was a spur-of-the-moment thing
of course Carlson hopped into this
tournament and I figured let's let's
track some of his games and we got to
see a good 50-plus of them and in
all-out berserk in all-out berserk
Carlson hyper bullet Carlson anyhow as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
and I hope you enjoyed it not sure how
much education there really is for
something of this format but if it was
fun for you to watch that's all for now
take care bye
you